A recent article published in the online
magazine Slate, brought to light the unexpected possibilities
when you participate in services like 23andMe.
The story was about a woman named Jackie
and her brother Alex who participated in
23andMe in the spring of 2012. Jackie and
Alex opted in to the relative finder
program that 23andMe offers. The result would turn
out to shock them. 23andMe listed Alex, Jackie's
brother as Jackie's uncle because they shared 25%
IBD. Now Jackie and Alex had spent their whole lives together growing up. And
and Jackie knew Alex couldn't be her uncle. Or could he? Choosing from this list
of possible family member options, I want you to tell me which of the following
relationships could even share 25% relatedness or IBD with Jackie.
Remember to check any and all options that you think apply.